après 2 ans d'expérimentation le
dispositif ensemble à 100 % se clôture
il proposait des parcours à la carte
pour remobiliser et accompagner des
personnes éloignées de l'emploi le tout
grâce au numérique c'est un dispositif
expérimental qui vise à accompagner des
personnes que l'on appelle invisibles
dans les quartiers prioritaires de la
politique de la ville qui sont en fait
des personnes éloignées de l'emploi et
qui sont pour certaines d'entre elles
même plus inscrites à Pôle emploi et
cetera les accompagn pour les ramener
vers la formation et vers l'emploi pour
ça on on utilise le numérique non pas
comme forcément un savoir-fire mais
beaucoup plus comme un moyen pour
pouvoir aller plus vite pour pouvoir
être plus dynamique pour pouvoir rester
relié avec les autres personnes et
avancer à son rythme mais toujours dans
l'engagement et dans une aventure de de
remobilisation en quelques chiffres
ensemble à 100 % c'est 2 ans de
programme d'innovation sociale
expérimentale l'accompagnement de plus
de 450 personnes éloigné de l'emploi
l'accompagnement de 267 jeunes de moins
de 26 ans et 227 femmes c'était vraiment
éclatant parce que en fait c'est cette
démarche c'est une démarche qui va
révéler les la les capacités des gens ce
qu'on appelle l'owerm la capacitation
donc c'est vraiment cool vous avez des
gens qui arrivent chez nous qui sont
plein de doutes qui ont l'impression
qu'il sont pas capables qui savent pas
très bien ce qu'ils vont faire et puis
en fait dans cette dynamique qui à la
fois une dynamique collective et
individuelle ils vont se révéler
découvrir des talents prendre confiance
en eux oser postuler à des choses et
cetera donc c'est vraiment très cool de
voir comme ça les gens comme éclore et
comme se révéler à eux-mêmes grâce à
ensemble à 100 % 25 % des bénéficiaires
sont entrés en formation à la fin du
parcours 17 % sont en emploi durable CDI
et CDD de plus de 6 mois deux des
bénéficiaires ont créé leur entreprise
ce que j'en retire c'est beaucoup de
positif puisque ça m'a permis
aujourd'hui cert de trou trouver un
emploi mais également d'interagir avec
beaucoup de personnes
passionnées qui dans leur domaine ont à
cœur de de les partager j'ai aussi un
peu plus de connaissance sur qu'est-ce
qu'on a besoin sur le territoire et
comment je peux me rendre utile à
travers les compétences numériques que
j'ai acquises j'ai fini auto
entrepreneur ce qui était pas le projet
de base j'ai fini a tempant entrepreneur
et je suis plus que fière des
connaissances
et des des liens tis on est vraiment à
l'air du numérique et tout le monde a
besoin pas de se sentir à l'aise dans le
numérique donc ça c'est vraiment en plus
c'est pas du gâi c'est pas du temps
perdu c'est vraiment en plus 100 %
gratuit ce dispositif était financé par
le ministère du travail de l'emploi et
de l'insertion et par la banque des
territoires